if you're trapped in an elevator with
someone and they say hey boy crisis like
what do you mean what do you say to them
i say boys all around the world and all
56 of the largest developed nations are
falling behind girls
in every single academic subject
especially in reading and writing doing
well in reading and writing is the
single biggest academic predictor of
success boys are more than twice as
likely to be diagnosed with adhd than
girls more than five times as likely to
find themselves in juvenile detention
much less likely to graduate from high
school if they do go to college they
will find themselves comprising only
40.5 percent of college students if you
don't go to college then you're
struggling to find a job between the
ages of 10 and 14
boys suicide rate is twice that of girls
between that of 15 and 19 is four times
out of girls and between the ages of 20
and 24 it is five times out of girls
income for men has declined in real
terms since 1990 almost 15 percent of
male community college students dropped
out in 2020 alone about one-third of all
men are either out of the job market or
unemployed or have dropped out in some
form or fashion that number is
mind-blowing boys are more than twice as
likely to die from opiate overdoses as
girls are deaths of despair among
middle-aged men are reaching record and
unprecedented levels so if you trace it
from boyhood to manhood it all looks
rough and we have men out there who have
no sense of purpose who are not being
taught to love and be loved and we
really need to make it part of our
national calling
to say to men we need you as we have in
the past
you